Somewhere between your last birthday and
this exact moment, something shifted.
You felt it. That subtle earthquake when
you realized the ladder you've been
climbing might be leaning against the
wrong wall. Here's what nobody prepares
you for about turning 50. Success feels
different. Those achievements you chased
are in your rear view mirror. The view
ahead looks completely foreign. The
truth that hits you at 3:00 a.m. is that
you have more yesterdays than tomorrows.
But here's the pattern interrupt
everyone misses. This isn't a crisis.
It's an upgrade. The 50's reality is
powerful. You finally have the
experience to know what doesn't work,
the wisdom to recognize what does, and
just enough urgency to stop wasting time
on anything else. Welcome to the decade
where clarity leads the way. The time
where wisdom meets opportunity,
experience meets energy, and everything
you've learned becomes everything you
create. Your 50s aren't the beginning of
the end. They're the end of the
beginning. Everything until now was
practice. This is the performance.